jean boucher français de messier ont
vécu ensemble 50 ans les deux touchés
par la même maladie rénale
ils avaient tous deux été greffés seule
la mort a pu les séparer
60 ans mais pendant 50 ans et puis vous
avez dit m il était temps de mettre fin
au parcours leur santé déclinait ils ont
voulu terminer leur vie au même moment
jeudi dernier ils se retrouvent côte à
côte près à recevoir l'aide médicale à
mourir
entourés de leurs proches les cinq on
est vraiment à regrouper on se tient aux
colons juste avant l'injection d'eau
bouchées adresse un dernier message à sa
femme qui vont marquer le restant de mes
jours c'est mon père que dans les
dernières minutes de didier moment que
le passé cinquante années de 150
baleines bonheur qui me souhaitait la
même chose à moi est plus que qui les
met donc à puycalvel eu le privilège
selon heureux de partir ensemble
jean françois boucher souffrent de la
même maladie rénale et a aussi bénéficié
d'une greffe
il raconte cette histoire pour changer
le système québécois actuellement un
donneur doit avoir signé sa carte pour
qu'on puisse prélever ses organes
il propose qu'on ait versé le système
c'est que tout individu est un donneur
automatique de ses organes à son décès à
moins d'avis contraire donc les gens
conservent leur liberté de dire qu'elle
refuse donner leurs organes
c'est ce qu'on appelle la présomption au
consentement de dons d'organes qui
pourrait être une solution à la
stagnation du nombre de grèves dures et
au québec les ya à peu près une famille
sur cinq malgré que le dollar avait
donné son consentement qui vont refuser
le prélèvement d'organes fac donc s'il y
avait le concept mat donc présumer
constate yves baron pour avoir moins cet
obstacle
le deuil est lourd pour les proches qui
souligne cependant que le couple était
assez serein pour vouloir écouter de la
musique
même quelques minutes avant leur départ
le temps qu'il aurait pu lui faire
écouter et son fils dit avoir reçu le
plus beau des cadeaux
deux sont atteints mon paradis qui était
racketté cher damois défiera de la
personne que j'ai fait et puis j'ai pu
au moins me faisait rire quand même que
je l'aimais jusqu'à ma mère ici david
gêne-t-il airs et au canada mourir